All right, we are going to get started.
>> I am the proud principal of Oaks.
[cheering]
[applause]
>> [cheering and applause]
>> I am the proud principal of Oak Springs
Elementary School and uh we are glad
that you came out um just to kind of get
a
clearer picture of what is happening in
our district. um the needs, what we
understand, what we know [snorts] and uh
decisions that are being made and um to
have our voices heard um and so that we
can do what's in the best interest of
everything. And there's so many entities
that's included in the decision making.
And so um as the person for Oak Springs,
I'm definitely grateful for our
superintendent Matias Sigura being here
with us today. So thank you. Thank you
so much.
Um and um we love this place and so we
are just um thankful that you are going
to listen and hear um just what we
believe as people in this community what
is best for this community. So thank you
for being here and uh I'll turn it over.
Hi everyone. Um I'm Christina Wyn. I'm
the uh director of communications here
in Austin ISD. And I just want to thank
everyone for coming. Uh and before I
hand it over to our superintendent, I
just want to acknowledge, you know, the
weight of why we're here today and
understand that they're really difficult
conversations and we are definitely here
to listen to hear new ideas and make
sure that um we can really move forward
with the best plan for this community.
>> So with that, Superintendent
Um, so I know Christina already said
this, but uh, you are taking time out of
your day. Um, and I know this is a very
painful, disruptive process. Uh, you
know, there are families, there are
communities that are being harmed. I I
want to acknowledge that this is not
easy. Uh, so just very much appreciate
you all showing up. Uh, you love your
school communities. You know, I love
this school district. Um, and so I just
I just want you to know I know this is
tough. Um, so I really appreciate you
showing up.
What I want to start off with is um the
the why overall and then talk about kind
of how we got to this existing draft
plan. And it is a draft plan. You've
seen us make changes. I want to continue
to refine and improve. Uh, but for us as
a school district, I want you to know we
have not
been ensuring that every student gets
what they need to be successful in
Austin ISD. That's the honest truth. Um,
you know, students that that look like
me are black and brown students
historically in Austin ISC have not
gotten what they need. That's just we go
back decades, go back half a century.
The data is there. We understand that.
As I think about who we are, this board,
this administration, we are desperately
trying to disrupt what has historically
happened.
And it's hard, y'all. It is very, very
hard because these things that we have,
these habits that we've built up are in
our bones. And if we're going to move
forward,
we have to be willing to make some
changes.
When I think about what we need as a
school system, I think about strong
neighborhood schools. And you see that
behind me. And I want to talk about what
that means to me. And it means that our
families have access in their
neighborhood to a school that meets
their needs, that sees the true identity
of the students in that neighborhood. We
have families right now that have to go
across town or feel that they have to go
across town.
We have communities that get split up,
go to multiple high schools, multiple
middle schools.
And so when we think about where we want
to be as an organization and how we're
going to support our school district, we
need to have strong neighborhood schools
in every part of the city, not just in
some parts, in all parts.
And I am someone who believes, and our
board believes too, that students need
different things.
And some communities need more. And I
want to be able to provide those
resources.
When we took this work on, there were
five things that we were trying to
address all at one time because it had
to be big. It had to be
right. You know, the pressures that we
have right now from the state, lack of
funding. I've got to ensure that our
resources are where they need to be to
keep teachers in the classroom. The
federal government changes have hammered
us.
We've title two, title three, title four
dollars frozen, hundreds of people
impacted.
We think about the loss of immigrant
families who had AISD at home who've now
chosen to leave.
All of that has put immense pressure on
Austin ISD.
And so when we took this work on, there
were five things, like I said, that we
wanted to tackle. first and I strongly
believe this has to happen and I do not
want to leave the superintendency
without taking this on and that's having
a line feeder patterns not just in West
Austin but throughout Austin and most
importantly in East Austin you do not
have that right now we do not have
aligned feeder patterns what does that
mean I've got middle schools like Mendes
and Martin that go to three four and
five high schools
you cannot create community when you
have those types of splits.
Do you know where you have feeder
pattern alignment in other parts of
Austin where the entire middle school
goes into the high school? So, we knew
that if we were going to do something,
we had to align feeder patterns. So,
that was one aspect of the work, but
that requires touching all the
boundaries. Two, we had to address our
transfer policies.
We got transfer policies in place for
decades
that are moving kids, moving families
out of this community and other
communities just like it because there
are different things that they desire in
different parts of the town. And we
understand why those were in place. But
if we're going to become the
organization in the school this school
district that we need to be, that I
believe that we can be, we have to have
strong neighborhoods in those schools so
that our families pick them.
So, we have to address that because
they're they're old. They need to be
updated. They need to be refined. And we
have to make sure that we control them
and not have the local
um pressures impact the way one uh
school may get overenrolled or
underenrolled because of how they manage
transfers locally. I would say three, we
have to address this budget deficit.
Y'all, I this is real. We have been
working for the last year and a half to
drive down our costs. We've cut over a
hundred million dollars in the last two
years. I've downsized central office. We
have found opportunities to reduce cost.
But at the end of the day, we simply
have too many schools in Austin ISD for
the number of students we have. We have
116 schools with 70,000 students.
I'm going to kind of take you back um to
1996.
We had about 90, it's kind of funny. We
had 96 schools in 1996 and a roughly
70,000 students as well. So, we grew
with the city and then as affordability
hit us and as things changed, we kept
our buildings. And so, we've got about
20,000 extra seats in Austin ISD. And
they're not all in one place. They're
kind of spread all throughout. you think
about the number of seats, that's more
than we have actually um when you think
about the um Moody Center, that big
stadium downtown. I never been in it,
but that thing there there's more seat
there's there's we have more seats empty
than are in that building.
So, we had to address that because the
way that we support our system is by
providing the resources. But when you
have more seats and more portables and
all of those things, it costs us more
and we're not putting money where it
needs to go, which is in teachers and in
programming. The other thing, the Texas
accountability system, not the Matias
accountability system, not a board of
trustees accountability system, the
state's accountability system
is very rigid.
I say and our board will say to our blue
in the face, our students are so much
more than a test they take on at one
time of the year, right? But that is the
measurement stick that the state uses to
ensure that all students get what they
need to be successful. Again, that's the
state. So in 23
after multiple you know with 23
accountability didn't come out till this
year
there were 30 F schools not us but there
were 30 and 24 which came out shortly
after three months later because of the
lawsuits we had 29 and then a couple
months later which is August of this
year we had 23. So the system is moving,
but the reality is that because 23, 24,
and 25 all came out within five months,
if we do not address the accountability
risk and break those chains,
then the state intervention, the way
it's designed is you have fewer and
fewer options as you continue to receive
unacceptable accountability ratings. So,
we have to break them. We just have to.
And I want to be honest with you, we
need to pour more into our students.
It's not our students fault. It's AISD's
fault. Like we are the system that's
producing these outcomes, but we need to
do it our way. And so I have to break
those accountability chains because I
can tell you that the state takes this
very seriously.
If we do not respond,
the state will continue taking
interventions up to
right installing a board of managers.
And what that essentially is is a board
is a board takeover, a district
takeover. We do not want that. I promise
you, we do not want that. The local
leaders who you've elected need to be in
charge of leading the school district.
It has to be that way. if they come in,
they will not do the things that we
expect they would do. It'll be very very
different and we have to protect our
values. And so I just want to be really
honest like I have to account for that
in this plan as well. The last thing
I'll say is we wanted to make sure that
any program that we support wall-to-wall
dual language programs, monastery, and
many others, we need to ensure that
they're sustained moving forward. Right?
Has the program evolved to a point where
the original focus is no longer the
focus or no longer kind of the original
intent is being met in the way that it
was intended like from when it started.
If that's the case, we need to make
adjustments to ensure that we have the
student population to ensure viability
long term. So this plan is
comprehensive.
There there are lots of pieces in it.
Um, as you know, I've recently sent a
letter out talking about breaking up the
milestones on it. We'll talk about that.
I'm very frustrated that we're here. Um,
I'm sad that we're here, but not doing
something is not an option for us if
we're going to continue to be who we are
as a school system. I will make
refinements. I will change. But the one
thing I I won't do is just
not make a change. Uh, not while I'm
here as a superintendent. And I will
tell you, our board is very much aligned
in wanting to move forward and implement
true meaningful change. Um, so the plan
for Oak Springs, I will tell you, it
breaks my heart and I'm very frustrated
that we're here because we in 2024, and
2022 most notably, but then again in
2024, um, committed to build a new
school here, right? I was part of that
work. Like that's what I want. That's
what we wanted collectively
when we arose when we arrived at the um
kind of plan to kind of make uh a a kind
of a recommendation for a change. One of
the things we had to acknowledge is
there aren't as many students living in
the area as there once were. If
everybody in the neighborhood came to
the school, it would still not be full.
That's the honest truth. So we had to
make a change and [snorts] we looked
about looked at the schools around. We
think about alignment and demographics.
We think about alignment in culture. Uh
black shear was the kind of logical kind
of blending partner.
The reason it was identified as black
shear before because I think this is
going to come up because people are
going to ask Matias why did you go that
way opposed to this way? is because we
had heard through the long-range plan.
We had heard through our time in the
community in years that the historic
school at Blackshere was something that
was needed to be preserved and protected
which is why we went that way. Um I am
want to have conversations with this
community. I want to ensure to everybody
listening that I care about our staff.
We have plans to support our staff. I
care about our leaders. We have plans to
protect our leaders. We're going to do
this in an ethical, thoughtful way. Um,
but I want to have a dialogue so that
you know kind of where we're at. Um, but
I'm committed to progressing and
refining and improving. But what I can't
do is is nothing. Um, so I just wanted
to to kind of pause uh and share that
and then create the space for you to
answer to ask questions like tell tell
me what um would be helpful as we
transition into this next phase of the
work or what options you would like us
to consider as we move forward because I
am committed to exploring those and
progressing that work. Anything? How do
you want to do this?
>> No. Uh, we do have some comment cards
that I I think your principal said we
could start with and I think uh we can
address some of those and maybe that
will build on the conversation if you're
good with that
>> or I want to make sure it's it's y'all's
time. Anybody have questions you want to
start off with and then if it's kind of
lows down then we can go to a comment
card.
>> Yeah, I do.
>> Yeah. Do you want
>> Yeah. And and just to let y'all know we
do have ASL interpretation and Spanish
interpretation. So we will ask you to
just talk into the mic to make sure we
um have that. Yeah.
>> And these don't have
>> Okay.
>> Sorry.
>> You know, thank you for coming out and
making time to speak to us. Um, Oak
Springs as a title one school. A lot of
our kids are are the most vulnerable and
I was happy to see the consolidation and
the change of hopefully bringing both
Black Shear and New School along with
Oak Springs. Um, one concern that I have
is even for our fourth and fifth
graders, you know, for next year trying
to make that um, that trek to Oak
Springs because a lot of them, like I
said, may not have transportation. Um,
it's still a concern of them crossing
those train tracks without any sort of
uh, alert if it's coming and, you know,
going through the neighborhoods, past
the homeless shelter. So, you know, our
kids are still even in fourth and fifth
graders or 10 to 12 year olds that would
probably be tracking this, you know, 30
minutes to school and home, you know.
>> Yeah.
>> Can appreciate, you know, my family will
definitely want to stick with AISD and
that's always been the way. You know,
I'm third generation and hopefully my
kiddo will be a Marine, too.
But we have a lot of vulnerable babies
here that are depending on us to try to
get them to school and home safely.
>> Yeah.
>> And um you know this is a real concern
for our young ones.
>> So um so thank you for sharing that. I I
want to make sure I understand um
precisely
uh the the question when it comes to
student movement. So we as AISD have the
ability to provide transportation
right and and make adjustments based on
the needs of the students right so so
one of the things that I have heard as
we've gone through the plan is that
there are um students here that would
have um challenges kind of getting
safely to blackshere
>> right
>> and and and and so one of the things
that we can uh consider and absolutely
commit to is providing that
transportation um you know this is where
kind of the local planning comes into
place like I need to understand you know
that nuance like where do we need to
provide the transportation you know to
ensure that it is done in a way that
that I can support which is whatever the
students need or what we're going to
support but when we look at it as a
whole until we have that conversation
and plan um I can tell you I can commit
to transportation but I can't tell you
precisely what it will look like so so
so I want you to know like that yes, we
can do those things. But it sounded like
the beginning of the question was
something slightly different.
>> Well, only because with the new build
that we were planning on here, it was
supposed to open in 2027.
Maybe consider that it's just the fall
that our kids would have to try to track
over there and maybe we can open the
school with both of the schools in
spring of 2027 and stay on track.
>> Okay.
and maybe just kind of tighten that
timeline.
>> So, in the document that we released, we
talked about continuing to explore um
Blackshere and Oak Springs. Um and and
we haven't kind of revised the kind of
finality or like the updated
recommendation because we wanted to have
these conversations with community, but
it sounds like what you're are are
wanting or suggesting or wanting us to
pursue is to well, not only that, but
also to have Black Shear move to Oak
Springs ultimately long term.
>> Well, like I [applause]
Next,
>> sorry kids,
>> just so we can
>> I just want to make sure I want to be
really precise like in what I'm hearing
just
>> only because Black Sheer itself is a
beautiful school and offers a lot of
supports, but it's even older than Oak
Springs
>> and the maintenance.
>> Anybody who does any sort of maintenance
know it's expensive. It's costly. And
instead of constantly repairing and
mending, why not put those essentially
taxpayer bonds that we approved for a
new school to actually have the new
school built for the kiddos?
>> Yeah. And and this came up
um we were at a meeting um
[clears throat] at uh with Reverend Lans
and we had a community meeting out there
and um and that was something that came
up which is actually what spurred the
conversation that allowed me to get
comfortable putting in a document so
that we could have these conversations.
Now I don't want to have these
conversations without black shear
together, right? right? I mean, we need
to talk about it and have and make sure
we're all on the same page, but I want
to do what's best for this community and
and as we move forward, it needs to be
both of us talking together. Um, but I
also want to understand more like, you
know, kind of how what that could look
like because I I will tell you I want to
I want to do what's best for this
community. I I really do. Um, and so I
appreciate that comment.
>> Okay.
>> Is there anyone else that would like to
speak?
>> Okay. Can you come?
>> Thank you.
>> I have a student who's on a 504 plan and
before we came to Oak Springs, we went
to a she went to a really great school
in a really great neighborhood. She did
not excel. It was it was really hard.
And then when we moved out of there, you
know, I was afraid bringing her to this
community. You know, everybody knows
it's the east side of Austin and you
know, Booker T is street. I was afraid
that she wasn't going to soar, that she
wasn't going to come out of that shell.
And being here, because there's such
small classrooms and there's a lot of
one- on-one with the teachers, every
single staff member in this school
actually knows every single kid by their
name.
>> Yeah.
>> But [applause]
and
since then, her her um scores have gone
up. Um, I get every day I get something
great from her teacher, from the
principal, from the vice principal, you
know, everybody's got something great
and and it has really helped her her
enthusiasm, the way she feels about
herself. This school has done that and
and I don't know about everybody else,
but I'm afraid tearing away this this
family that has grown here. So many kids
have gone from here and have graduated
at East Side, have graduated from
Johnston High School. You know, so many
people grew up here. And I want that for
her. I want that community. I I don't
want it to be, oh, we live in the
projects and that's what it is. No, when
she walks across the street and she
comes to this school, it's something
different than what's across that street
right there. And that's what I want for
her. I want security. And I want that
for all these kids, though. And that's
all, you know, it's not just about it
being across the street either. It's
about what has been created here. You
know, these kids come here and a lot of
them come from broken homes. A lot of
them come from one parent homes. Mine is
being raised by her grandmother. A lot
of grandparents are raising their their
grandkids. And for them to come to a
school where it's a second home and
these people love our kids and they
protect our kids like they're their own.
That's what we want. Yeah.
>> You know, and
>> like I said, y'all poured a billions of
dollars next door. We got a school that
could be already going up and up, you
know, and and bringing a a bigger
community together. Why waste all that
money that AISD poured into that ground
right there? That was groundbreaking.
That was something this whole community
from here all the way to to the highway.
We got kids in Marshall apartments that
[clears throat] don't even go to Black
Share that go here,
you know? So, why is it about tearing up
a community? Why don't we pour into the
schools we have right now? You're
talking about the teachers aren't
meeting the requirements. Let's talk
about teacher pay, though. You know what
I'm saying? Like our teachers deserve to
be paid more. Yeah.
>> You know, they don't just deal with
teaching our kids. They're dealing with
a lot more than that. They're fighting
for our kids every day.
>> Yeah.
>> And I just want them to know that we're
fighting alongside y'all. You know, we
want this for our kids. I want this for
my granddaughter so much.
>> So, that's all I got to say.
>> No. So,
[applause]
so I I let you respond real quick and
then I we give the question.
>> Um,
>> sorry. Can would you mind coming up so
we can have
>> Thank you.
>> No,
>> thank you sir for being here. Of course.
>> Yeah. My name is Charles Miller and I
was born and raised in this community on
on the hill up there. And I was just
thinking it's it's like we the we're the
oppressed and they're the oppressor.
Isn't it a way that
I had two relatives that worked at
Blackshire and I know the population has
changed because of you know
demographics, gentrification, etc., etc.
So it seemed like they would it would be
at a greater advantage for them to bring
their kids here rather than for us to
have to go over there. I mean what do
you think about that? I mean because I
know that that school is not the way
that it was when I was growing up. It's
it's a total different population.
>> Yeah.
>> Great resources.
>> So So I I want to respond to that and
then respond to your question um because
I I want to make sure I get both.
>> So I I want when I when I said earlier
how we arrived at the initial draft
plan, it was truly in response to the
historic nature of Blackshirt. Um and
and what I've learned as I spend time
with community and this is why these
meetings matter. Like when I tell our
trustees, when I tell our community
like, "Hey, I'm trying to learn to make
changes and to refine and to approve,
I've been I've been told for years,
Black Shear's historic. Zavala is
historic. These schools are historic and
important in the community. And if
you're going to make changes, make sure
you don't go there." And so, as we have
conversations and the community is
saying, "Well, maybe we can think about
it differently as long as we do
something over here as well, but maybe
not have to be what it was." and we're
still moving in the same direction. I
can support that. I just want to be
really clear like that that I I I can I
want to make sure that we do what's best
for both communities. I am 1,000%
supportive of putting students in
modernized facilities. Right? That is
important. That's why I made the
investment. That's why I like advocated
to make sure there's an investment here.
That that was part of the work that I
led. Um so I that's not off the table.
It's just I need to make sure that we
spend time here making sure this is
something talk to Blackshere, have a
conversation with our trustees and then
see if we can move forward because I
tell you right now two separate schools
that are a little over 200 students is
not viable long term. What we need to do
is to figure out how to bring the
community together, plan together, put
an investment together and and continue
on and then like essentially move
forward. um you know you so that's what
we're here for like so so that is I
would say that's why I put it in the
document we're still looking at this you
know but what I need to understand is
what do I need to do to make sure that
that other um concern that arrived that
got us to this point about the historic
nature of black shear what would meet
the community desire right and ensuring
that we also do right by that and and
that's what I need to hear more about or
we need to kind of work through to your
question ma'am
Um what what you just said is what we
want for our students. I'm I'm so
>> I just love that you shared that about,
you know, your student here at Oak
Springs. I agree with you. We need to
pay our teachers more. And I want you to
know we have been fighting. Our board
and I have been fighting and and making
investments in our teacher. When we came
together in 2023, we did the the biggest
raise that we have in over 30 years for
teachers. In 2024, we made another um
compensation increase. And in 2025, yet
another. So, we need to continue to pay
our teachers so they have a chance of
being able to afford to live in the city
that they serve.
>> So, I just want you to know like I am
fighting those pe those educators and
those staff that that that know kind of
what's occurred um you know probably
have a good sense of it. But I wanted
you to know in our committee member that
we have been making these raises since
we came together with this board, this
administration. And again, there were
significant raises in 23, 24 was a tax
rate election which the board supported.
we got across the finish line and in 25
was by way of HB2 and we're going to
continue to fight. I want money to go to
teachers and programming, not to
inefficiencies in our system.
>> So, thank you. I just want to
>> Yeah, we have one comment that connects
to this um real quick before we get to
our next question. Um it's occurring to
me um as [clears throat] we're speaking
about Black Shore being historic and
like you said Zavala being historic and
what came to me is that it's not the
building that makes the community, it's
the people.
>> Yep.
>> It's um
the people that form the history.
Um
like Mr. Miller.
Uh like um what is your name?
>> Renee.
>> Like Renee.
Um like Miss Synagog.
>> Like myself.
I've been here for 14 years.
And so, um, we shouldn't lose sight of
that important point that it's not the
building,
it's the people.
>> Yeah.
>> Thank you.
>> Thank you so much for that. [applause]
>> Thank you. Because I know it's been very
brutal. I can't even imagine being in
your position. But anyway, I just want
to say
Black Shield is very historic
for our African-American community. Oak
Springs is the same way.
>> It has to be a way, and I'm just
throwing things out there.
>> Throw them out there
>> that we can bring both together
so that I just don't want us to lose
what LC Anderson lost.
>> That's our history. I don't want to lose
what Keeling lost. That's our history. I
grew up on the hill, walking up and down
the hill. Those that know about this
community, it's important to me. I don't
want to see Oak Springs get lost because
of this environment. We know this whole
community is changing.
Even if we had a bus for our children
that picks them up, our parents when we
have literacy night and our PTA meetings
and everything else we have, our parents
come across the street. They don't have
transportation.
A lot of them are disabled. They can't
get a bus to go to Blackshere. I want
our kids to be proud of the building
they are going to. It's hard when I see
kids, we outside and they say, "Man, we
don't never get anything new." It breaks
my heart to hear a child already
identifying the difference because of
the skin color, the way they look. There
has to be something. And I know it's all
about the budget. I understand that. Can
we do something? Talk to the We talked
to the black share people. Bring them
over here. Combine them. Maybe this is
for the primary or the intermediate and
the other one goes over there. We all
know that these charter schools are
poaching our kids. The black and brown
kids, that's what they do. We have a bus
that stops right here that picks up a
whole bunch of kids off the butt to pick
them up. We can have those programs.
You're talking about having our march.
Let's have a program like they do in
Northwest. Let's have a program. Let's
have languages not only Spanish but
let's bring some other German other
langu and let it follow and let us all
work together with feeder schools. We've
even tried to reach out I'll say I have
to keeling last year year before last
work with our kids. We want to do a
yearbook. Can your yearbook staff work
with our kids? Can we follow it? We've
even paired with east side. So there are
ways to do this so that our kids are
truly title one kids here. You
understand? You know that I doubt, not
saying nothing, but I doubt a lot of
those kids in Maplewood go through the
struggles that our kids go to every day.
Every day we got kids parents being
picked up by immigrant. We got parents
being arrested right in front of their
own kid. We got shootings right in front
of them. So we deal with that emotional
piece and for them that it's still there
for them. I want to give them something
or can we try and give them something to
make them proud of their community? They
see everything going up around these
these million-dollar homes. They see it,
but is it for them? No, it's for
everybody else.
And so that that is my heart and that is
my passion, not only as an educator, but
also just this is my community and I
want to see it. And another thing too,
why do we get rid of our our historical
schools that were only for the black and
brown families? Why do we always get rid
of them and not find a way to bring them
together? And it just, you hear the
comment, if you got the money and the
resources, you good. If you're not on
each side, you good. But it's always us
that has to make the sacrifices and we
have to make like you said the hard
conversations. It has to be a solution
to help with both schools [snorts] cuz
both schools were built for a purpose
and served only us and to take that away
is just it's heartbreaking.
>> Yeah. So, um thank you for the comment
and I appreciate you being there at the
a couple nights ago, I guess a week ago.
Um, so
I I want to so I I I just want you to
know um I love this this school district
and I love our I love our
how we have as a board and as
administration have made decisions to
protect history that might have
otherwise not been protected. Right. I
mean I working at Eastley College High
School with the alumni the LJ alumni to
really preserve the history of Austin
ISD. That's work that that I led, the
work that we led together with our
trustees. So I I you will find someone
in me that is always going to try to
protect the rich history in East Austin.
Just I want to that is that is who I am.
Now, when I think about these two
schools, um, Black Shear and, uh, Oak
Springs, the reality is that there are
so few students here, and when I talk
about all the things that we have to to
work through, the reality is if one
little thing goes wrong, and I mean like
one family moves out or something
happens, the accountability system is
adversely impacted. I mean, it's just
like up and down, up and down, up and
down. And yes, we can pour in resources,
but at the end of the day, the system
isn't built for for people that look
like us. I mean, that's just the honest
truth. So, in order for us to be
successful, we have to have more
community together. So, when we talk
about having two separate schools, I
don't know that there's the ability for
us to do that. I just don't think that's
viable. Now, I think that there's a way
if we work together with the Blackshire
community to find something different
than what we have in place, but I don't
believe that there's the ability for us
to continue to have two separate schools
of a little over 200 students. That that
is really hard.
>> Have we thought about doing any type of
Have we thought about doing any type of
programs to bring them to our
communities like some of these same
other schools on the west side of town?
bring them into our communities that
will attract those kids back to these
schools, to our schools.
>> You know, I I worry about I mean, yes,
you can. Um, this community should have
something for them. Uh, you know, it
should be something that that doesn't
require other communities to come in to
be successful. That that's that's what I
believe should happen. Um, but we're at
a point now with all the pressures that
we have to adjust to take this next
step. Now, we can be creative on on
repurposing. You know, there's things
that we've done. I've talked to
communities and they say, Matias, like
we want to make sure that there's
children in these buildings. We can do
those things. It just won't be a school
in the same way that it was before, but
it doesn't mean that it has to go away.
So, I I that is that is the type of
conversation I think we can have. We're
just not able to have two schools that
are a little over 200 students. We can
add the programming. We can do those
things, but what if they don't come
right? What if one more year hits of
account unaccessible accountability
ratings and then this this school is at
risk of closure, not because I want to
close it, but because the state is going
to close it. That is what I have to
avoid. That's what we need to avoid
together. So, I'm open. I want to have
those conversations and talk about those
ideas, but I'm here with you. like I I I
want to figure this out, but those are
the constraints that I just have to
operate within.
>> All right, let's get to the next
question.
>> All right. Um, so my name is Sherwin
Patton and I'm I'm here with a group
called Dream Together 2030. Um, but the
reason why I'm standing in front of you
is because um, Tiara told me that she
was going to come speak,
but she needed support in coming to
speak.
So, let me tell you this. Um, nobody in
this community should have to stand
alone.
>> And so, that's the reason why Dream
Together is here because we are here for
the community that is being directly
impacted. Now, I'm indirectly impacted.
And the reason why I say that is because
I'm I'm probably one of the few people
uh in this room that's been in East
Austin for um 55 years. And I I still
live in East Austin right now. So, I'm
up the street. And so I'm right there by
Blackshere Elementary School, but we do
ministry over here at Book of T. And we
know the students and the families that
are right here. Some of the students and
the families that are right here at this
school go to the church that I get the
opportunity to to pastor.
>> Yeah.
>> And so this is the the thing that I I
have a question about. Um because I love
the fact that uh Archbishop Lans um and
uh and trustee um Bradley had that
conversation with you about a possible
um merger of both Black Shear and Oak
Springs. That that's a great that's a
great um conversation that's being had.
And we don't have to lose the historical
value of Blackshire because we can
repurpose Blackshere and make sure that
we use that for some type of early
childhood education or something um that
helps to continue to build up the
community as well as make sure that we
continue with this new construction that
has already begun that have been voted
on here in this community. And after we
listened to the voices of the people who
have come up thus far, their voices have
said, um, we want to see this school
stay here and we want something new. So
my question is this. Um, and we did have
a conversation, I just full
transparency, we had a conversation
earlier today, Dream Together 2030, on
behalf of the people who live here in
this community because we were talking
about what we heard from you all. We do
not want anybody who is directly
impacted to be moved from this school.
We support Booker T. Washington Housing
Complex. We support this community. If
you're part of Dream Together 2030, will
you please stand up? Dream Together
2030. We are here with you.
We're here with you. [applause]
So, you do not have to stand by
yourself. Now, my question is this. um
if we invest in this community because
the reason why I believe that we see a
lower attendance here at this school is
because when you don't invest in a
building, if you don't invest in the
community, if you don't invest in the
people, then why would people want to be
in that place? I mean, it's been a long
time since there's been an investment in
this community. there has been
divestment in this community and we see
um investments all around us but we
don't see investments happening here. So
my question is this is the school
district willing to walk together with
us because u we want to support you. We
really want to support you
superintendent Sara. We want to support
you as you support us.
Is it possible for the school district
to invest in this school?
Have a conversation between Black Shear
and Oak Spring so we can talk about the
possibilities of all of us being in a
new school.
Then the last part of that and then
together envision what we're going to do
with the historic Blackshere Elementary
School. Is there a possibility for that?
And then I'll end it with this. Um, I
care about Blackshirt because my my
mother went to Blackshirt. Um, my father
went to Blackshire.
>> Um, a lot of my family went to
Blackshire, so I understand the
historical value of it. So, we're not
saying uh that we want to neglect
Blackshire,
>> but we cannot neglect Oak Springs
either. The people who live across the
street, and I'll be quiet after this.
This year alone,
we've watched three different murders
happen in that complex. Yep. More than
that.
>> And and we've wa we've watched kids
leave from this school
and walk around tape.
We watched it.
Sean and I went over there one day right
after the shooting had happened
>> and had to help kids to understand that
you cannot play on the police tape while
they're doing an investigation.
So, we're saying that we don't want to
invest in a community that's already
going through stressors like that.
That's not what you're saying. I know
it's not what you're saying. So, what
I'm looking for is for you to give us an
opportunity to partner with you because
you have to be successful. You have to
be successful for this community to be
to be successful. Are you willing to do
that? That's my only question. Are you
willing to partner with us to ensure
that we can make build this new school,
partner with Blackshire, reimagine what
that historical building can be over
there and help this community that needs
help from you.
>> So you you have my commitment to do the
work to partner with you and the
community. I want to make sure that the
community together, Blackshere and Oak
Springs are at the table like
facilitated by you. So, just in full
transparency, who did you meet with
earlier today?
>> Oh, yeah. We met with uh you don't have
to help me with the names. We uh Miss
Drinks.
>> Lisha Drinks, chief of staff who reports
to me.
>> Yes, that's exactly right. So, the chief
of staff and then we also Stacia and
she's in the room.
>> So, I I And the reason I want you to say
that is because I want you to know when
we hear something and we and we think
that there is an opportunity to to do
something, we begin to work. like, you
know, I knew this meeting was going to
take place. I wanted to have community
voice, but based on we heard um at
Calvary and based on the conversations
we've had since then, you know, we're
working. And so, if you partner with us
and with Black Street Community to solve
and figure this out, like, you got me.
We'll be there for it. It's going to
have to go quickly. And the reason is
because there are state requirements
regarding um accountability. Now, one of
the things that will have to happen is a
move is going to have to occur. Period.
But the question becomes where do you
end up right because like you said the
construction you know we have to break
the account accountability chain which
means there's going to have to be a
blending in order to do that from the
state requirement. Um but I am committed
to having that conversation. You met
with us earlier. We're going to progress
it. We got to be attached to the hip and
we got to go like we we have to work.
>> We're ready. So this is the B part of my
question. Give him a hand of applause
because that's a commitment. That's a
commitment. So the B the B part of that
question is this then because the the
meeting with Blackshirt is Monday,
right? I think
>> um I I I I been running uh you know
>> I think it's Monday. I think it's
Monday, but and if it's not Monday, then
we we'll find out the date. But we have
a Dream Together 2030 meeting on that
Thursday right here at Oak Springs.
Dream Together 2030. And so, and
actually, if you're part of the
community, you do want to make sure that
you come back out then because we're
also going to be giving out uh free
turkeys to everybody in the community so
you can have for Thanksgiving.
But, but the other part of that is um
can we invite at that meeting Black
Shear to be a part of that that
gathering because Dream Together is
about us being able to create spaces
where we can have these intentional
conversations and really learn from one
another. So, Dream Together 2030 is not
about pushing an agenda. It's about
bringing us together. So, is that a
possibility?
>> I I would say we have a board meeting
that night.
>> Okay.
>> Um that's the 14th, I believe. Right.
>> It's the 13th.
>> Uh is it Thursday or Friday?
>> It's Thursday. The
>> It's the 14th is a Thursday.
>> We have a board meeting, I think.
>> Oh, no. We have But
>> you're on Wednesday.
>> We're on We're on th the 13th. So So
>> Okay.
>> Yeah. So we're on the 13th to Thursday.
>> Next Thursday.
>> Okay. So next Thursday the board
meeting. Okay.
>> No. Yeah. Next Thursday y'all's board
meeting next Thursday.
>> We have no
>> No, we have one tomorrow and then the
20th
>> and then we have uh No, the 20th is the
board of vote,
>> right? So you have So you have
information session tomorrow and then
you have the following Thursday um an
update to the plan. So we I'm just we we
will meet but I I want to make sure that
we're meeting um often.
>> Yes. because every there are timelines
that I have to meet to to to get this
across the finish line. Okay. The board
vote because of the turnaround plans is
November 20th. That is the state
requirement
>> and whatever we talk about between both
schools will inform that plan which
means that I need to have like both
communities progressed along and and
enough support where I can take it to
our trustees with over a week's time
like because because this is how it's
supposed to work, right? We have a tab
tab plan. We were fine. We were fine. We
improved. We improve. But at some point
because of open meetings act, I have to
post.
>> And so we need to go. So let's work
through what that looks like. But I I
just don't want to take days and days if
it needs to be back to back to back to
get this work done.
>> Okay. And I I I'll end with this because
I need to turn it over to uh Terra. Um,
so will you all just look at your
schedule and consider the 13th? Because
as you just finished talking, it just
reminded me if we need to move fast and
the 20th is coming up the following
week, then it's really good that we have
a meeting that's on the 13th and the
board meetings is not till the 14th
because possibly you can make it on the
13th. So I just want just consider that.
Check your schedule.
>> We're I'll be there.
>> All right. Thank you.
>> I just want to clarify one thing just so
to further like just so everyone is on
the same page. I think so on the 14th we
have to post the final recommended plan.
Whatever the board is voting on on the
20th needs to be finalized by the 14th.
So that's why I think the 13th may be
cutting it a little bit too close
because we would so I I think yes we
will continue talking but that's just
the rationale for like Friday has to be
like and and to be perfectly honest it
has to be even before that because we
have to translate it get it everything
accessible and designed to be posted on
the website. So really like by that
Wednesday it needs to really be done.
>> We'll we'll figure it out.
>> I just want everyone to understand.
Yeah. Yes. Okay. Sorry.
>> I'm a little nervous.
>> Um hi, my name is Tiara Clark. Um I've
been an Oak Springs parent for eight
consecutive school years. Um I have two
children that's been here since preK3.
My oldest is going to middle school next
year.
Um,
and as I was thinking about it, you have
a percentage of children that looks
forward to coming to school because who
knows what's going on at home.
>> Yeah.
>> Um,
let me see. I wrote it down, y'all. I'm
trying.
>> Oh, you you're doing you're doing great.
>> I'm trying to
>> You got it. [applause]
Um,
who's to say that these children will
naturally adapt to a new school setting?
Um, who's to say that their behavior
won't go down here because they feel
that they don't have that safe space
that they have here at Oak Springs? Um,
>> um,
Um
so my question is
are we going to take away these kids
safe space?
So, um, transition is is is in the
details, right? So, we are committed to
providing the supports to to ensure that
all of our students transition into
whatever is next, you know, whether it's
plan A, plan B, um, whatever we decide
on, it's it's we're going to get there
together. What I want to be really clear
about is we have um, Staca, where's
Staca at? Staca Pascal, who's who's back
here. So she is the person who's
overseeing our bridge teams.
>> Okay.
>> And our bridge teams are groups of
individuals who are ensuring that all
the transitions that occur are student
centered that we um really consider and
invest and make sure we have resources
deployed to understand that you know
mental health supports you know any
other things that we need to consider
for the student um well-being is
considered. This is above and beyond
just programmatic alignment. This is
above above and beyond just bringing
PTAs together or CAC's together. This is
truly um you know what the student
needs. Now the the plan requires
bringing your community and you know
Black Shear together to figure out what
do our students need
>> and so we don't have it detailed so you
can respond to it because what you need
may be different than what another
school will need.
>> But I'm committed because we've already
have the structure in place of deploying
the resources
>> and I will tell you that the one thing
that we need is time. We need time to
plan. So, um, having the vote on
November 20th will allow us to move
forward with staffing, building up the,
um, the plans, uh, make sure they're
supported and they're inclusive of
community voice. And then the spring
semester, um, we deploy the resources,
we continue the planning, and then we're
ready to go. Do any adjustments over the
summer, and then we launch the 26 school
year like in a good spot. What is hard
is whenever decisions get delayed or if
we don't come together and create that
plan until spring or later. It really
should be thinking about and doing that
work now. So that's that's why we're
going to do it that way.
>> So yes.
>> And then so what what what does it mean
for a lot of the teachers?
>> Yeah. So um I've been very clear
>> like for them.
>> Yeah. So I've been clear um and I want
to be really really clear. At no point
along the way did we ever say that a
single educator, professional educator
would lose their job at Austin ISTD.
Period. So I just want to be really
clear. That's the first thing. And that
I want to also say that from my
perspective includes um classified
staff, which is custodial staff, food
service workers, everybody else who is
part part of the school community that
is an AIC employee will be supported and
will have a home. Just to start off
there, when we think about the staffing
plan, um, every staffing plan is going
to be different, right? So, if you have
two because the turnaround plan
requirement is part of this plan,
>> we are going to have certain
expectations that we have to meet.
They're not AISD's only expectations.
The state of Texas, they're saying,
Matias, if you're going to bring two
schools together and you're going to do
a turnaround plan, I need to make sure
that each teacher has two years of
experience or more. Right? there going
to be certain things that we have to
make sure are considered. Now, once we
um have homes for all of those staff and
anybody that is still needs a home, then
it becomes, well, what is their
preference?
>> Um we have surveys that are going out.
We have teachers and educators that are
saying like, hey, I live here, but I
really want to see what this experience
might be. Then we will um um place them
there if it aligns with that staffing
plan.
>> Okay? And if that doesn't work because
it that maybe it doesn't a good not a
good fit, then we have matching fairs
only internal to Austin ISD where we
say, you know, these are the
opportunities we have. We're going to do
it in February. We're going to do it in
March so that everybody has a home
starting with their preference and the
community's needs and then as we go
through the spring semester, we will
make sure everybody gets a home. We are
not opening it up to any external hires
until April. So that's how we're going
to approach it. Um, that is our
commitment. We hire uh lots of staff
every year. We do not have to hire
outside staff. We have the ability
uniquely because of our size to find
homes for everybody. Um, so that's how
we're going to do it. I'm I'm very I I
want to be I I am very keen on making
sure I stay close to that and ensure
it's done with fidelity.
>> And I just got one more thing to say
questions, more comment. Um, because Oak
Springs, it's not just a school. It's
>> it's a support. It's a support system.
my
Oak Springs itself, not not just
Principal Synagal, not just Miss Boo,
not just Miss Hunt, not just Miss Brown,
I the school itself. Um,
I've been through a lot
these last two years. I just lost my
baby in June.
And Oak Springs has been here for me and
my children, all three of my children.
And my youngest one don't even go here
yet. But we were looking forward to
that. But I love our springs. Team Oak
Springs, baby. Team Oak.
[applause]
>> Hi. I just want to say I went to Black
Church in Rosewood and I have been in
this community, but I would like to see
if uh the community wasn't supporting,
we wouldn't got out and voted for the
bond to be passed to build the school,
the new school. So this community,
Austin, small community is being kind of
like destroyed. And I feel like Austin
independent is not making the uh city
council
accountable for running students from
Austin with not having affordable
housing. It's not just the problem that
y'all don't have nothing but 200
students there. Y'all have let Austin
run most of the students to Mayor
Blugville and all other charter schools.
So that's my issue is why is Austin
Penny School District as y'all uh board
of trustees not trying to
advocate and stand up to Austin and say,
"Yeah, y'all can build these highrises
and apartments. Y'all can tear down
Booket, any projects that y'all want to
tear down, but also y'all are destroying
our community for our kids to have the
to live in Austin as a community. That's
what my problem is with ASID. All these
years that um my kids was in school and
my grandkids was in school. Um,
Austin Independent School is is just not
going to it's not standing up. We
already know that y'all let we we had to
let charter schools in. Now the charter
schools are taking over. Most of the
students are going that way and that's
reality. Like you said, you don't have a
student. I know you have a problem too
with the being accountable for the test
scores and stuff like that being low,
but also when you keep um I mean when
y'all just don't address some of the
real issues like even like LBJ, they
didn't even have a band because
when they do get to middle school, they
don't even have nothing but two little
classes that support band. those band
students can go on and get scholarships
for for college. Y'all not even doing
that. That's why a lot of of the other
parents are saying, "Well, you know, let
their kids go to a charter school
because it's not giving them any other
advantage. Y'all not given the advantage
once they do get out of this elementary
state and school that they'll have a a
fighting chance to accelerate and
[clears throat] be more productive in
the in and stay in this community.
>> Yeah. No, thank you for that. Um, a
couple things.
Uh the first thing I would say is you I
and our trustees advocate for AISD all
the time. We we advocate at the state
legislature. We advocate um you know
with our city council members. And yes,
you're right. We are in an environment
where accountability and housing, which
is something we don't control, um but we
are impacted by uh is imp it hurts us.
It it really hurts us. Um but I want you
to know we are trying. Our trustees work
hard. they are having these
conversations. But to your point, you
know, these are decades long right to
before we got here and and I acknowledge
that. But we are are very much trying.
>> My mother is 87 years old. I take her I
have to keep you
going
as a child. And y'all keep on just
I know it's not just on your level but
you know I was saying the test scores
because you know are below
>> and they're moving we're moving them
they're moving in the right direction
>> but they were slow because we shut down
school they don't try to combine like
different other schools once they get to
junior high that's schools are all great
because a lot of
I guess their beginning starts at
elementary whether they learn or not you
know but once they get to that junior
high level that's where y'all fall off
at because
>> the communities the educational teachers
it just seemed like y'all
give up
>> yeah so so um this is why aligning
feeder patterns is so important for East
Austin that's that's the honest truth
when you have community gets split up
you know programming goes one way
students go another way. There's there's
no feeder. There's no alignment. That's
what gets weak programming. So, I'm
trying we are the board and I are trying
to address that. Now, it's going to take
a little bit longer, but we are going to
address. Other thing I would say is, you
know, LBJ, Nor Eastern College High
School, East Side Early College High
School, we have been investing and
supporting these schools to try to to
get get them to be um as strong as they
can be. And and I will tell you,
Northeast Early College High School in
2023 had an F, a D in 24, a C in 25. LBJ
has moved, right? They are a C now. And
the the school um when you talk about
chronic absenteeism is way down.
Enrollment is up. We invested in the
health science program there. It is it
is moving. And so I desperately want to
create alignment so that our students
see themselves at LBJ or at East East
Side Early College High School when
they're in elementary and in middle
school. So we are working. Those schools
are moving. I don't want I want our
community to know I mean LBJ ESA I mean
these schools are moving. They are doing
great work. And here's the thing is
disruption has caused that previous um
performance right now. We have
stability. We have teachers coming back.
We have aligned curriculum. It is
working. We got to keep going. So I just
want every I want everybody to leave
here thinking that I mean those schools
are are rocking. Like LBJ and Nor
Eastern are like doing amazing amazing
work. East side as well. I'm really
proud of that work. Um, so I just want I
just wanted to share share that. So
thank you. I appreciate it.
>> Thank you. Our next question is from our
deaf and heart of hearing community. So
we are going to have our ASL interpreter
ask.
>> This is really tough for me. Uh so my
oldest son uh he transferred uh to Black
Shear School. uh my my son uh
transferred there and he was bullied. It
was an awful experience. And so I guess
my question is how can you can guarantee
the safety of our kids when they go to
Black Shear from our school here where
they're comfortable and safe and not
bullied? How can we avoid all of that
happening again?
You know, if they go to Black Shear,
then how are we going to, you know,
prevent bullying in in a bad hostile
situation from happening?
And I feel like, you know, if uh if we
do end up going to their school, you
know, we'll be labeled. We'll have this
that and the other stigmatism and we'll
be looked down upon and the kids will
say, "Oh, they're from the projects or
whatever." And I just want to know how
our kids are going to be safe over
there.
>> Yeah. So, just to be I mean,
you have to look at me, right? Oh,
>> I'm sorry.
You go first.
um
bullying,
right? That type of um behavior can
happen in many different schools. I
don't want anybody to think that it's
just a specific school. Um, you know, we
in Austin ISD
have been very intentional about
providing the professional development
to teachers and our principles to ensure
that whenever we see it, we provide the
right resources to our student so that
it doesn't continue on. Um, but it does
happen and so I don't I it's not
necessarily always a school by school
issue. It can happen in lots of
different places. Now to your question
around Oak Springs and Blackshere coming
together, that is why the bridge
planning work is so important. We need
to make sure we hear each community's
voice, bring the communities together
and ensure that we have a successful
launch to a school year with both school
communities. The the way that you don't
do that successfully is you don't plan
and you don't have the resources to
deploy to ensure success.
>> Yeah. But do you want to come here? Sa
>> I can hear your concern and know that it
is the heart of what we do. So I use a
transformative seal lens to all the work
that I do. So I just want to give you an
example of one of the types of supports
that we provide to campuses. In the
mornings, students participate in
morning meetings and it's a way to build
community to um have students to share
the things that are important to them
and it allows them to find
commonalities. And so part of our work
on the bridge team is being very
intentional with the type of morning
meeting prompts as well as how we use
inclusive welcomes and engaging
strategies throughout their
instructional day.
You need a state question.
>> I do
>> I do have a second question.
>> Sure.
>> Um
so I just wanted to ask reiterate why
can't Black Shear, you know, just come
here. Um, and if they don't want to come
here to the new building, um, if we are
forced to go over there, then I guess my
follow-up question would be, um, you
know, the after school programs here are
so amazing and, you know, parents can't
afford them and the ACE program here is
phenomenal. So, will we still have those
opportunities if we are forced to go to
Black Shear?
>> So, we will provide the programs based
on community and student need.
All right.
So,
you know, it it is up to the plan like
to you Oak Springs and Blackshere, you
know, to we need to understand what is
our what do our students need. We can
move programs. We can easily do that.
Um, we just need to make sure that we
have the space to support them, which
I'm sure we can do, and then we move
forward. But yes, whatever services and
supports our students need, after school
care or otherwise, we will provide,
especially in the instance where these
school communities, um given kind of the
historical inequities, uh we we're going
to be very intentional. Um I'm committed
to doing the work to determine where we
end up. Uh this is why this conversation
is important because again, it's it's
not final yet. This this conversation is
important. It really is.
I just want to reiterate, I think it'd
be in the best interest if we all stay
here and just move into the new school.
I just feel like it's not very fair to
uproot all of our students lives. It's
just not fair for our kiddos.
>> I understand.
>> Thank you.
Now, you know, I tried to be quiet. I
sat over there. I said a prayer. I
prayed,
but I I just couldn't. Matias, you you
said some things. One thing you said is
about a TEA takeover. If the TEA if they
took over the school, then it wouldn't
be what we expected. Well, guess what?
This district has not done what we have
expected.
It has never done what we have expected.
This will be the second time this school
has tried to has where the district has
tried to close it. They don't look at Go
Valley. They don't look at Artega, but
they'll figure out how to save those two
schools, but we can't figure out how to
save this one of Black. Now, I know if
you think about it, you can come up with
something because it makes no sense for
this school to close. The apartment
complex is right over there. You have
Elmbridge. You have Marshall. That's too
That's too much. That's too much. The
other thing is
I'll hold you harmless for the first F
for the failure of this school. The
other two Fs are on your watch.
You've got to build up this school. You
can't close it. To be honest, you don't
need to close any school that has an F.
You all need to be thinking about how
you can lift it. Once you've lifted, you
can start looking at boundaries. You can
start looking at um you can start
looking at consolidations and closures,
but you at least need to focus on the
academics of this school. The other
thing is the targets you guys have are
ridiculous.
That doesn't say we have any expectation
of black and brown kids. It basically
said, "We know they can't do it,
>> so why even try?"
>> No, I've seen the I know. Uh oh. No, no,
no, no, no. I've seen I've seen the
targets and they're lower for black and
brown children and espec especially
black black children because in because
in science
the targets are lower for black children
than they are for special ed students.
So, don't tell me. I saw it. No, go back
and look because evidently you're not
>> I'm very familiar, but I'll let you
>> No, go back and look because I was
watching the board meeting where they
were um it was a science and they were
excited about the scores. I couldn't
understand why the targets alone
and I mean it was like 17% 18%
20%.
go back and look at it, you'll see I'm
writing. The other thing, if you can put
a pause on Brierwood,
on Maplewood,
on palm and the boundaries, you can put
a pause on everything else because all
you are saying,
and I don't know if you realize this,
all you are seeing is white privilege
matter and no one else doesn't. is
privilege matters. No one else doesn't.
And I've said this when I was on the
board and I'm saying it now. Nothing is
ever done for us. It's done to us.
>> Hello.
>> I can respond. I I mean I know Cheryl
and I go back a ways.
U as y'all probably um so first off I
want to communicate we in Austin ISD
disagregate all our data scorecard
everything. We have very aggressive
goals for all of our student populations
students identified as historically
underserved including you know um
economic disadvantaged students uh
Hispanic students African-American or
black um we have very aggressive goals
on a per year basis like we have to
climb. That is the honest truth. uh
where we're starting isn't acceptable
and we have to move and so our overall t
target is very aggressive and we're
moving and you know we talk about early
literacy early numeracy there's a report
that we're going to share tomorrow where
we actually exceeded all outcomes and
our greatest exceedence the where we had
the most growth was students re the
receiving special education services and
African-American and black students they
met they passed 2425 and 2526 targets
and are approaching 26 27 like I am
committed to having aggressive goals
I have to have resources to do it. I
just want really really clear like it's
not there's not infinite resources for
me to do it. We're an inch deep and a
mile wide.
>> Let's let's have attract other people
just the way they attract us to go to
their schools.
>> We have no programs here for our kids
>> and and we will we can add programming.
I I that's not the the challenge is the
number of students that we have and and
and that live in the area. And so I want
to find a solution that that meets all
of these existing constraints. Um I'm
working I want to work with you. You
have that commitment. Um and so I I just
I just want you to like I am committed
to doing that work.
>> I real quick I do want to just clarify
because I've heard programs a couple of
times. I'm wondering if you can touch
real quickly on like the academic
framework work that's happening um to
really get that baseline offering before
adding any more. Um
>> yeah, so so one of the things that we
talk about with our trustees and with
our community is what should our schools
expect to have and what do we um want to
ensure our student experiences are in
all of our schools, right? So that when
you come to Oak Springs, you know
without a doubt you're going to get this
type of education. You're going to have
this type of rigor and we're going to
have these expectations. We go to
different schools around Austin. I know
that there are different expectations. I
see it. That's unacceptable.
And you can see it in the work,
>> you know, and and so for
>> that doesn't fall on the educator. No.
No, no, I know it fall it falls on. So I
need to create the system that ensures
that we have rigor, we have expectations
as a culture, right? Where everybody
sees that no matter color your skin, you
have the ability to succeed. Period.
That is not what we're coming out of
over 144 years. We are trying to move
it, right? But to do so, we need
resources. We have to be thoughtful in
our approach. We have to be aligned. And
that requires these types of changes. I
mean, that's the honest truth. We're not
going to be able to get out from the all
of this weight unless we make some
changes. Um, and so the academic
planning that is part of our work. I
will tell you that the last three years
it's been urgent, urgent, urgent, the TA
greeted order, you know, moving forward
in our systems to actually so we can
understand where our students are,
multi-ter systems of support. We have
aligned curriculum. We're doing all
these things and our outcomes are
moving. Um, and so as we move forward,
we're going to work in the spring
semester to build out our academic
framework, academic vision, which is
something we've been wanting to do. It's
just that with all the things that we've
been faced with, it's really hard to
focus on the important because all the
urgent work is like here, like the risk
is real. Um, and as we move forward, you
will have the understanding this is what
you can expect in this vertical team.
This is our expectation around the
curriculum. These are the things that
we're going to protect. If you go to
this school, you will have a librarian.
You will have this number of
instructional coaches. we will have
these supports. Right now, I can't I
can't ensure that because we we just
don't have the resources, but that's
where we need to get to.
>> So, um my name is Victoria and I serve a
unique role here at Oak Springs. So, I'm
a staff member, but also I'm a parent,
too. And so I just wanted to touch base
on some of the parents what they said of
our campus is a safe campus for our
students because all three of my
children either my oldest is 15, he
attended Oak Springs and then my two
younger ones do too. And as a staff
member, you can choose any school for
your your students to go to through
AISD. Yeah.
>> And I keep choosing here because the
safe environment and how my kids feel.
And so even with my oldest son, he went
to many elementaryaries and then once he
got here in fourth grade, he thrived.
And so for him to feel that and for him
to feel safe, it was just it's alarming
to uproot our community and for our
students too.
And so um
I just really wanted to talk about our
safety concerns for Oak Springs because
um from the students walking to Black
Share, the majority of the Oakspring
students, it's roughly 116 kids walk
home either alone with siblings or with
their parents and sometimes us staff
members walk them home too. So that
community and that trust, they trust us
to walk them home, make sure that they
get home safe. Um,
so either that they would have to cross
streets and with reckless drivers. In
the past, Oak Springs has had two
students get hit by a car just crossing
from the school to Booker T. The need to
cross train tracks raises the following
concerns. There are signs that state no
train horn. Students, families would not
be properly alerted when the trains come
in. So that's another safety concern for
our kids. So I'm just speaking on behalf
of them.
Yes.
>> Yeah. Um so thank you for that. Um you
know we can provide with whatever
happens right planning wise you know we
are able to make um changes to
transportation routes depending on how
the move ultimately works. That's where
it's coming down and understanding what
is happening happening locally to ensure
that our students are getting to and
from school safely. Um we have the
ability to provide transportation. and
we look at hazardous routes, hazardous
intersections, that'll continue, but we
can also make adjustments beyond that
and we have so um I I want to work with
you. Our team is working with you so
that when we have an implementation
plan, it considers all of that. Uh
that's what we have to do. I do not want
any student to not be safe getting to
school. And here's the other thing is
sometimes you got to use it's got to be
different and that's okay and and we are
committed to doing that. So I just you
know we we can do that. Okay.
>> Thank you.
Okay, ready? And I just want to make a
note on time because we only have our
interpreters until 5 and so we have
about seven more minutes. If anyone else
wants um to ask a question, if y'all can
come up.
[clears throat]
>> All right. Sad to say is that we meet
like this again. Um
my concern is that uh I've seen Dobby be
put through this. Do we middle school,
Web Middle School, Vernon Middle School.
I heard that Martin as well is being
closed down. Or
why is it that the time and the amount
you say that you know, you want to work
with the plan to make sure that you can
invest in our communities. You know, you
love our communities and I want to
really believe that. But a lot of the
times is
a couple of weeks to make a decision
that is going to change decades,
centuries of community history, families
that have been affected by it. And to be
told, you got till the 20th,
that's like not even two weeks. Uh what
is being done to learn from the
situations that have been put in other
schools? you know I
>> so um what we learned from Dolby Burn
and Web right because I remember we we I
we've had conversations before um those
turnaround plans uh we were given those
timelines in
uh I think February 19th or March like
or 28 like somewhere right at the end of
February of last year and then we
disagreed on Dolby and it wasn't until
about a month later when they said, "Oh,
you also have to do web and burn it."
Because it was federal and then state
was released. So, what I'm what the
reason I'm saying this is because the
what we learned is that if you're going
to do anything well, and this is
something I've always believed in, you
need time to do it, time to plan. In the
spring, we had to get the vote to by
June 12th. it'll be in June 20 26 but we
had about two and a half months right to
have the conversations but then to build
the plan uh the reason the 20th is the
timeline um is not because Matias wants
the timeline to be the 20th because the
state of Texas requires that the
turnaround plans for three UA campuses
which Oak Springs is be submitted and
accepted by uh November 21st that is a
state of Texas requirement and so it
doesn't have to
everything that we're going to do,
right? We can build on that plan. We can
expand on it. We can work through
December and we can refine and we can
improve, but the elements in it, the
ones that have to move in order to break
the accountability chain must be
included if it's going to be accepted.
So, that's why it's it's the 20 that
that date is is firm. Now, when we move
through this process, uh there there was
a lot that we were working through. Um,
I I want to acknowledge that there's a a
compression of time, which is why I'm
trying to find the space to work work
and get it done. Um, but that is why
that that date is is firm. I can't move
it back. The state of Texas won't let
me.
>> And why the time crunch? Why the time
crunch? Like, how come it wasn't
something that this meeting should have
been had a month prior?
>> Yeah. So, it came down to when we
released the draft plan October 3rd. Uh
at that point um there was those
conversations the week, the third, the
fourth, the fifth, and then we began
having just community meeting after
community meeting after community
meeting. We had the three district-wide
and then I'd be going to every single
community and having a conversation like
we're having here. Um it it was it was
just a function of, you know, us being
able to to get together to engage. But
as as we were talking about along the
way, we have been getting feedback and
and uh comment cards and having
conversations before this meeting. So
it's not like we're leaving this meeting
and saying could we do this. We've been
exploring it and seeing if we could so
that when we come back together in the
very near future, I can say yes, we can
go. Is there alignment between Blackshar
and Oak Springs? Do I think I have
trustee support to actually get it
across the finish line and then move
forward. So, we've been working um and
and I I will say that it doesn't have to
have happen without me in the community,
but I know that uh it's really important
for me to be there and hear it because
I'm the one that's ultimately
responsible. And um I don't know if you
remember correctly that when we were at
Dolby, it was three things that were
offered to us. It was not like, hey,
let's figure out something that could
benefit our communities. It was more
like this is your only options. Either
take it or let's stay. The three
strategies being a reassignment, right,
uh to a school and we had that
conversation, right? We just to I we
talked about it, went and had a
conversation. It didn't it it wasn't
going to be a direction we could go
because the community had shared with me
Matias we don't want to go that way,
right? So I listened, I learned, I
adjusted.
>> Next question was, do we do a restart?
Well, if we do a restart with an 1882
partner, which is the other option,
option two, then all the staff are not
AISD employees. And what I and then all
the programming, fine arts, you know,
athletics, all those things are not
under our control. What I heard from
community is Matias, we don't want to do
that. So that left me the only option
which is the one I believed in which is
we restart with AISD control. So So in
this, in this case, it's different
because you have elementary schools, not
middle schools. So they're smaller in
size. You have two schools that could
come together without having this huge
impact across the entire district. Like
middle schools are different. just the
impact of high schools, elementary
schools. So it is different in that way.
Um but that is why those decisions and
those opportunities were available then
and why these are available now. Um is
that makes is that helpful a little bit
maybe?
>> Yeah. And I guess I'll just finish with
this. It's really hard to see that we
have schools that obviously have a
different demographic that don't have
any of this issues and we don't
implement anything saying okay well look
we see that these schools in these areas
are thriving uh haven't had any issues
like that what is this community looking
like what are we investing in the
community and what are we not doing in
these communities and I believe that
I've always grown up you know going to
uh Keeling you know uh it was Walnut
Creek
>> yeah And the neighborhoods that I see in
different neighbors neighborhood areas
is like y'all invest so much and make
the community look so beautiful. And
then in our neighborhoods, we don't get
a lot of that. So eventually these
schools start getting smaller and
smaller which causes like you said now
you have a decision to make which one do
we keep open. we can't have both schools
open is because we don't have enough
students in these communities which to
me I feel is like a lack of how the
young the lady said it's like it's not
for us like it's to us so when are we
going to get that so so the first thing
I would say is this administration like
the way that I work lead the work I have
been very clear about the priority that
we as a district provide to those
schools that have been historically
underserved um y'all may not know this
but there's a support and resource index
which I produced two years ago and it
says if you're in one of these schools
you will have our full attention. We
will not we will not um level in the way
that we would perhaps elsewhere. You
know when we're hiring we're going
through different processes to support
you if so we we try to train our system
to acknowledge that we need to put more
focus on schools that just have more
need. when it comes to like other
schools, I will tell you that um much of
what you see um isn't always going to be
best for this community. What I mean is
sometimes people say, Matias, why don't
you go get the teachers over here and
bring them to a school? And what I'll
say, you want to be really careful
because you want students that see your
child that understand the culture like
that, you know, that who they are. And
that is going to be different for stu
teachers here than perhaps teachers
elsewhere in the city. Um so we have
been moving you know the um vacancy rate
has gone uh way down you know hiring
principles you know years ago we hired
over 20 principles I keep saying this
because I don't I want our staff to know
and our families to [snorts] know
whenever you have new principles what
happens you have new teachers and and
that just kept keeps impacting our
system we have great educators like
principal synagog now and we have
leaders who have been here but that
wasn't the case three years ago right
now we have very little attrition
very very little that creates stability
and you're seeing that right now in the
outcomes like you this system is moving
I just know that right now we cannot
sustain with the number of re with the
resources we have we are we are simply
at a point with all the pressures from
the state and the federal government
where if we don't do something our
students that need those resources will
not get them and I don't want to be
there no I get that and at the end of
the day I just want to say is I get the
part that you're saying on that
eclectically but I'm talking about a
beautiful park a big park that makes
when because when people go house
shopping they like oh I like this oh
this looks nice oh man you know this is
a nice neighborhood we can feel like you
know that's what I'm talking about in
the community community like putting
these things that need to be you know
established so that when people want to
you know walk walk down the street they
say man I'm going to go walk go take my
kids to the park you know things like
that that's what I'm talking about is
investing in the community in the
settings in the places the things that
need to be you know restored or pretty
much built, but for the community, not
to be, oh, well,
>> the whole east side doesn't look the
same like everybody says, and that's not
even helping us. It's pushing us out.
>> Yeah. So, um, so I want you to know my
heart is is with investing in schools
that have been historically underserved.
You know, I I know we're talking about
Oak Springs and the investment and the
in the bond for this specific, but I
also want you to know like 76% of the
$2.4 4 billion dollars went to title one
schools in East Austin like in this
eastern crescent. That's the honest
truth. We're building, you know, Travis
Early College High School. You know,
Bernett is being rebuilt. There there's
a lot there's lots of things that we've
invested in and that I would argue 10
years ago, 20 years ago, that vote
doesn't happen. That plan doesn't come
together that way. So, I want you to
know like this board, this
administration, like we are thinking the
way that you were thinking. Um it's just
we're at a point where yes, we want to
continue to invest and I may I want that
to happen. It's just with the time and
the pressures, something has to give and
I'm trying to desperately get this
right. Um, but there's very little
wiggle room. Um, so having community
voice, having partners work through it,
help us get there, like I'm all in for
that. Um, but but that's why it is what
it is. But I want you to know like we we
are intentionally investing in East
Austin. Um, and so that's just work we
got to do. But but I the 2022 bond
program, the work that we did at all
these schools, like that's still going
to continue. and I hope that we get to a
solution that works, but it's going to
take us coming together and figuring
that out quickly.
>> Okay. So, we are going to have one last
comment um from Mr. Min uh and then I'll
toss it to you. You're good.
>> Oh, I can talk. Yeah,
>> thank you. Um I just want to provide um
some context and some clarity to uh all
of us about the three consecutive FS.
Um,
as you know, Miss Synagol came on board
um
the year of uh CO 19
and um for at least the next three years
we were understaffed
in grades one, two, three, four, and
five
to the point that [clears throat] Miss
Synagal
Miss Spoo,
Miss Brown,
um, Miss Lee
had to become teachers.
>> And so those three consecutive Fs
weren't and aren't a reflection of the
administration.
They're not
a reflection of the students.
Uh it's more of a reflection of not
having the teachers here.
Uh not having people who needed to be in
those positions who wanted to be here.
The people who are here, they want to be
here.
>> Yeah. They want to be here. the
principal who is here,
she wants to be here. And to remove Miss
Synagog from being a part of the future
of Oak Springs is graver.
Um
to remove, you know, the teachers
who are here.
um likewise um is a grave error.
So I just wanted to you know shine some
light on um on that situation and and
that is
a district failure.
It truly is it's it's an institutional
failure
uh of um not
being able to to provide the staffing
that we needed in those classrooms.
So, thank you so much for for coming
out. Um, we know you love this district
and we know you love this school
and um, we so appreciate you coming out
and we love you too.
[applause]
>> Thank you. Um, I know it's a tough
conversation. I'll be around for a
little bit. Um, uh, y'all may um, I I do
love this school. I I do love this
community. Um we'll be around to answer
any questions. Um
my cousin actually teaches here.
[laughter]
>> Um
you know, like
I'm just sorry that we're here at this
moment, but I'm committed to working
through everything I have to to get it
right as right as we can.
>> Superintendentbody
objects to it.
>> Yeah,
>> please do.
I I just want to I just want to pray.
Can I pray?
>> Yes.
>> All right.
>> But Father, we come before you thanking
you
that you are the one that sees all of
us. And Father, what we're asking for in
this community is that you won't let a
us versus them dichotomy exist.
that you would give us the wisdom that
we need to ensure that Oak Springs can
stay open, Lord God, while at the same
time not neglecting any child at
Blackshire. Father, bring this community
together in ways that we need. Lord God,
you know what has happened at Booker T.
Washington Housing Complex. And Father,
we thank you that most of the precious
diamonds that are in this community have
come out of this community, Lord God.
Father, this is not a black eye in our
community. This is a place, Father,
where people have risen, Father, from
nothing. and become something. Lord God,
we've seen it happen over and over
again. So, Father, we're praying right
now that you would not allow this
community to be disenfranchised,
forgotten about, or placed on the
margins. Father, we're praying in the
name of Jesus. I That's what I pray. I
pray in the name of Jesus, Lord God,
that you would move on behalf of the
people who are here. You said that
you're close to the brokenhearted and
you save those who are crushed in
spirit. Now, Father, we know that
Superintendent Saggera and his whole
team have a hard job ahead of them.
Father, I pray in the name of Jesus that
he does not see um us as attacking him,
but Father, we pray that we would see a
way to work together, Lord, so that he
can do this hard job of having to make
hard decisions. Show us how to do this.
Show him how to do this. And Father, we
pray that you would show favor to this
school. Now, the last thing I'm going to
say um is bless um Cynthia Synagal, Lord
God. Father, we thank you that you've
allowed her, Father, to be the person
who stood stood as the gatekeeper here
and made sure that all of these children
were kept safe. Even when violence was
happening across the street from this
school, it did not happen in this
school. So, Father, thank you for her.
We pray that you would continue to
encourage her, continue to use her, and
continue, Father, to give her wisdom to
know what you want to do in and through
her right now. I pray this in the name
of Jesus Christ. Amen.